Pete Carroll has been gushing about his
quarterback Russell Wilson and look I
believe that Russell Wilson doesn't get
the credit he deserves as a quarterback
I think people just write him off as a
runner who is part of a team that runs
and he's so much more than that
here's Pete Carroll talking about Wilson
getting off - in Carroll's view the best
start of his career I think he's off to
his best start ever I don't know what it
looks like numbers wise but I think it
is he's you know I don't think he's ever
been more accurate than he's been and
more consistent and in command of
everything you know so I think he's off
to a great start
I mean I don't care how big the numbers
are I'm not talking about how many yards
or whatever just his play has just been
really really sharp and the numbers
Chris do back that up he's got the
highest completion percentage through
four games now there's 12 more to play
yeah but completion percentage now is
higher than it's ever been for any of
his prior seven NFL seasons passer
rating higher than it's been for any of
his prior seven NFL seasons and also
yards per attempt higher than any of his
prior full seasons but it's only four
games when you it's when you look at his
career stats one of the things that
stands out and and this is one of the
things that we take for granted when a
quarterback is always healthy right but
you see games played in games started 16
and 16 every single year same thing with
that Prescott 16 and 16 and and Wilson's
only ever been injured once it was
several years ago he had a knee and an
ankle at the same time early in the
season he fought through it never missed
a game and I think will do everything in
his power to never miss a game and I
just think that I don't know whether
it's he's in Seattle or we attribute the
Super Bowl xlviii win to the defense
yeah that's all of that I still think of
him as a gunslinger but he doesn't get
the credit he deserves
no definitely not I mean not for a guy
that all-time quarterback rating is
second only to Aaron Rodgers I mean that
just that right there should go oh wait
I we've we've not you know valued this
guy properly but to echo what Pete
Carroll has said it's been phenomenal
and Russell Wilson is in the
conversation there you know right there
with Aaron Rodgers and Patrick mahomes
for the best quarterbacks in
it just doesn't matter what offense or
what's going on around the team they can
make it happen and you talked about the
completion percentage Mike that's where
I wanted to go because that's what's
impressive about Russell Wilson you know
a lot of times when I see high
completion percentage I go it's a lot of
dinking dunk there you know man you know
drew Brees last year phenomenal year but
we've talked about there was issues
about getting the ball down the field
stretching defenses out especially as
they got against the better defenses
down the stretch
Russell Wilson in that offense I mean I
complain about it on the podcast
sometimes what they do pass wise I mean
sometimes it's just hey guys run
straight and Russell will hit you hey
run straight and take a right and
Russell will hit you there's no like oh
my gosh you know magic going on as far
as pass game schematics they run the
football and then when they drop back
they look to like
strike and he is on the money playing
phenomenal and you're right Mike he just
doesn't get enough credit not only like
what's going on right now but just
career-wise or house special he's been I
remember last year they made the
conscious decision to tear things down
to part ways with several of their
high-priced veterans trust that they
could backfill with young talented draft
picks who will become the names that end
up being overpaid in the future and
building the team around Russell Wilson
there was so much resentment of him in
the locker room when he came in as a
third-round draft pick became the
starting quarterback he was always
viewed as kind of a company man and
really not one of the guys and right he
just continues to perform at a high
level and now they have guys in the
locker room who are behind him
completely and look at what we've seen
playoffs last year when no one expected
it right this year they're 3 & 1 and
they have a chance to beat the Rams on
Thursday night and remind everyone that
I remember last year Russell told me
after they beat the Lions it feels like
2012 all over again so that would make
2019 2013 and 2013 ended with a Super
Bowl win for the CEO you know yeah I
think he was a little presented in that
locker room and you're right that's kind
of hurt his overall allure to the rest
of the country and is he a company man
certainly I mean he is yeah a little
corny that way at times yes but damn
he's the ultimate professional
and if you really are a player on his
team or leading an organization why
wouldn't you want Russell Wilson you
know he's gonna do everything in his
power to win they've lost one game this
year and he threw for 406 yards and two
touchdowns and it wasn't his fault they
lost in the New Orleans Saints you know
he can't carry the ball or tackle people
on you know punt return let's not forget
that aspect he's been he's playing
awesome and I'm glad we gave him a
little notice of that today
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports